au delà des pyramides au delà de ce que
vous pensez savoir découvrez l'egypte
inconnu il y à de nombreux signes de vie
sexuelle avant le mariage
comment les égyptiens de l'époque vivait
et mouret pourquoi ont ils été abattus
ici c'est sinistre
les solutions habituelles de guerres
famines maladies
découvrez les étonnantes révélations de
la terre d'égypte dans le prochain
épisode d'égypte au delà des pyramides
[Musique]
quand on parle du caire la plupart des
gens s'imaginent un endroit comme
celui-ci un monde hors du temps où l'on
mène une vie tranquille derrière les
murs et les volets des rues étroites
rempli de parfum d'encens et le
claquement faible des dominos se faisant
entendre depuis un café somnolent eh
bien c'est exactement ce qu'on trouve
ici
cependant le caire possède une autre
facette qui caractérise peut être mieux
cette ville au commencement du nouveau
millénaire
[Applaudissements]
nous nous trouvons à l'entrée de la gare
ramsès au caire chaque jour deux
millions d'égyptiens viennent travailler
dans cette ville animée faisant passer
sa population à 16 millions c'est un
lieu de contraste et chameaux parcourent
les rues aux côtés de voitures
d'importation rutilante le vieux se
mélangent aux neuf on peut entendre
l'appel à la prière sur fond de musique
pop en regardant ces gens se dépêchant
d'aller au travail
on a du mal à imaginer l'egypte ancienne
mais juste l'autre jour j'ai vu passer à
pied le visage du pharaon akhénaton et
par ici un vieil homme est assis dans
les traits sont identiques à ceux de ses
dix premiers
les fantômes de l'egypte pharaonique
sont toujours présents il est seulement
plus difficile de les voir si l'on veut
rapprocher ces gens de leurs ancêtres
alors il faut sortir du caire
[Musique]
ici à la campagne il est encore possible
d'apercevoir des traces infimes de la
vie quotidienne dans l'egypte ancienne
un château fera semblant à celui ci
apporte de l'eau à ces mêmes champs
depuis l'époque de ramsès cependant la
vérité est que nous ne savons que très
peu de choses sur les gens qui vivaient
ici autrefois je ne parle pas des rois
des prêtres et des scribes je parle des
paysans qui produisent la nourriture et
des ouvriers qui construisent les
temples qui fabrique les toffes moules
les poteries façonnent les navires et
qui servent dans les armées les
égyptiens ordinaires sont pour la
plupart illettrés et par conséquent ne
se font pas entendre de la même manière
néanmoins aujourd'hui nous allons
essayer de les entendre
parce que l'histoire de l'égypte
ancienne est aussi leur histoire
[Musique]
le grand succès de l'egypte en tant que
civilisation ne trouve pas son origine
dans l'autorité de ces rois ou de
puissance de ses armées mêlant ceci la
riche terre noire de la vallée du nil
tous les ans sans faillir le grand
fleuve déborde jusqu'à ce qu'il recouvre
cette terre dont ils renouvellent la
vitalité en lui apportant de riches en
nutriments
c'est cet événement sol qui maintient
l'egypte envier empêche les déserts
d'avancé alors que les autres porteuse
de vie se retire les cultivateurs
retourne sur les terres et l'egypte
bénéficie d'une autre année de
prospérité
à l'apogée de sa gloire l'egypte
ancienne compte à peu près 7 millions
d'habitants soit environ la population
actuelle de londres la grande majorité
des habitants vivent dans des fermes les
cultures qu'il sème et récolte ne
servent pas seulement à nourrir leurs
concitoyens mais également de fondement
au système financier du pays
il n'y a pas de mener
les têtes salaires et achats sur le
marché se paie tous avec des matières
premières le plus souvent des céréales
[Musique]
hérodote a été très impressionnés quand
il s'est rendu en egypte et a déclaré o
l'egypte est un cadeau du nil l'egypte
un cadeau des cultivateurs égyptien sans
ces cultivateurs ce serait juste une
grande plaine au nom dé tous les ans à
l'époque comme aujourd'hui il n'y a
qu'un fleuve dans toute l'egypte c'est
le nil dont dépend tout ce qui pousse
toute la vie agricole fonctionne selon
un cycle bien défini
le cycle annuel débute lorsque les plus
d'été dans les montagnes de ce qui forme
aujourd'hui l'ethiopie et le soudan
viennent grossir le fleuve
lorsqu'il arrive en egypte le nil
déferle sur ses rives et dépose la
couche arable fertile sur les terres
cultivées ce qui permet à l'egypte de
vivre généralement on pouvait compter
sur le fleuve pour causé l'inondation
porteuse de vie chaque année
cependant il ya des périodes où
l'inondation n'est pas suffisante ou est
trop importante et les récoltes en soule
fous sont perdus
tous les égyptiens comprennent ce danger
leurs mythes et leur histoire
l'essence même de leur pratique
religieuse sont tous liés à ce fleuve et
à son importance cruciale dans leur vie
on peut dire que dès que l'inondation
commence à diminuer une pagaille monstre
s'installe c'est parce qu'il est vital
de commencer à préparer les champs après
l'inondation la terre est retourné
légèrement et ensuite les graines sont
éparpillés et sont enfoncés dans la
terre par l'action des pieds des hommes
et des animaux
les cultivateurs égyptien planque des
légumes et des légumineuses tels que
haricots et lentilles néanmoins les
récoltes les plus importantes sont
celles du blé de l'orge ces céréales
forment la base de deux piliers de
l'alimentation des égyptiens tout le
monde mangeait du pain peu importe la
classe dont vous êtes issue est
aujourd'hui encore en egypte esch le mot
désignant le pain signifie également vis
donc fondamentalement vivre c'est avoir
du pain tandis que le blé piles et
pourra faire du pain ont fait pousser
l'orge qui sert à fabriquer l'autre
denrées de base de l'alimentation
égyptienne la bière tout le monde boit
de la bière mais elle reste largement la
boisson quotidienne des gens du peuple
la royauté ou les gens fortunés préfère
le vin la culture de la vigne est très
répandue et le vin égyptien est
recherché par les connaisseurs de
l'ancien monde
des textes sur papyrus révèle que bien
que le pain et la bière fasse partie de
tous les repas quotidiens
l'alimentation des habitants de l'egypte
ancienne et variés et nourrissante
poireau oignon ail salades et concombres
sont des aliments courants les fruits
comprennent date me l'ont fixé grenade
et bien que les égyptiens ne connaissent
pas les agrumes ou le sucre ils
satisfont leurs groupes pour les
friandises
grâce à de grandes quantités de miel les
fermiers élève également du bêta et
cochons moutons chèvres ânes
alors que le port est courant dans
l'alimentation des paysans leboeuf coûte
généralement trop cher les travaux qui
ont été effectués sur les restes
d'animaux démontre que les gens
manifestement plus fortunés comme le
pharaon et sa cour on se met beaucoup
plus de boeuf que les gens aux moyens
beaucoup plus modestes ou les ouvriers
les égyptiens habitants toujours tout au
plus à quelques kilomètres du fleuve
le poisson est un aliment très important
le fleuve crée également des marécages
et paix qui servent d'habitat à de
grandes volées de canard et d'oie
migrateurs les hommes aussi bien riche
que pauvre chasse le gibier d'eau à
l'aide de lances grave est à la fois
pour le sport et pour la nourriture
ce gibier à plumes vient en complément
des canards et oies domestique qui
fournissent les oeufs la chair et la
grèce les poules ne sont introduites en
egypte que plus de 2500 ans après la
construction des pyramides
quand enfin les récoltes de son mur la
vie de la ferme entame l'importante
phase suivante dans le cycle rural la
moisson on coupe le blé et l'orge avec
des pierres bien aiguisé ou des
faucilles en cuivre ensuite on bat le
grain en pilonnant les épis comme une
pièce en bois comportant des fentes le
grain est séparé de la paille en le
secouant en l'air bien que les femmes ne
soient pas censés travailler aux champs
la récolte est une exception et tout le
monde y compris les enfants participent
[Musique]
en egypte la majorité des terres sont la
propriété du pharaon ou de grand temple
cela a pour conséquence de tempérer la
joie de la récolte avec l'arrivée des
représentants du propriétaire venu
percevoir leurs impôts on sait que
l'égyptien moyen n'accepte sans doute
pas de devoir verser des impôts à l'état
nous avons même trouvé parmi les
archives de l'élite dé référence au fait
que les percepteurs d'impôts doivent
s'attendre à rencontrer des problèmes
lorsqu'ils vont chercher les sacs de
grains chez les fermiers en fait les
percepteurs d'impôts viennent sous
escorte
ils se font accompagner par des hommes
armés de gros bâtons
à l'époque comme maintenant on encourt
des pénalités si lente riche sur ses
impôts sauf que la punition est alors
beaucoup plus sévère néanmoins même les
impôts le peuvent priver les fermiers de
la satisfaction que leur apporte la
récompense de leur travail
la moisson implique que le cycle de vie
dans la vallée du nil achevé sa saison
les égyptiens sont de nouveau à l'abri
de la pénurie pour toute une année
[Musique]
nous venons de découvrir à quoi
ressemblait la vie des fermiers dans
l'egypte rurale
cependant les anciens égyptiens avaient
également de grandes villes telles que
même fille c'était ben nous sommes en
route vers le site de ce qui était
autrefois une ville florissante
ici dans le delta du nil à environ 160
km au nord du caire
cet endroit a été renommé dans le vieux
monde pour ses vins et ses parfums
mais il offre plus de questions que de
réponses c'est un lieu très mystérieux
nous nous dirigeons vers le site de la
ville ancienne de mendes
la ville de mendes se situe sur l'un des
nombreux bras du nil là où ils se
déploient en éventail dans le riche
delta de nos jours les ouvriers plantes
du riz sur la terre qui faisait
autrefois partie de la grande ville
mendes fait ses débuts dans les tout
premiers jours de l'ancien empire pour
évoluer en un port de commerce animé est
un important centre religieux mais il
semble qu'à un certain point au cours de
la longue histoire de mendes la vie de
cette cité était interrompue par une
mystérieuse tragédie il ya plus de 4000
ans après 500 ans d'une incroyable
prospérité l'ancien empire s'est dissout
dans le chaos
nous ne savons pas pourquoi
on trouve ici des preuves du fait que
des gens se sont soudain entassés dans
la ville le feu la destruction des
enterrements fait à la hâte des familles
entières mourant ensemble les indices
classique de guerres famines maladies
[Musique]
il n'existe aucun document écrit que ce
soit ici à mendes ou ailleurs expliquant
le déclin de l'ancien antilles
cependant le docteur donald redford de
l'université de penn state en
pennsylvanie est à la tête d'une équipe
à la recherche de réponses
ils sont en train de conduire des
fouilles dans un temple de l'ancien
empire construit ici à mendes il n'y a
plus de 4000 ans alors qu'ils ont
découvert d'autres à 10 consacré au
culte
ils sont aussi tombés sur un lieu de
mort alors nous sommes sur le temple
maintenant qu'est-ce que vous avez
trouvé dans cet endroit
eh bien nous avons d'abord rencontré une
couche de destruction massive quelqu'un
avait allumé un feu à un moment et à
incendier les briques et elles se sont
écroulées dans un grand incendie et
ensuite sous cela nous avons trouvé une
surface associé avec la structure
qu'elle quelles étaient tes et sur cette
surface nous avons découvert une grande
surprise
l'une des grandes surprises de ma
carrière d'archéologues et une surprise
assez dramatique en fait
donald e m'emmène dans la partie la plus
sombre de ses travaux dans le temple
c'est ici que les ouvriers ont découvert
la preuve saisissante qu'il y avait eu
davantage cas d'incendié à ce niveau
exactement là où je me tiens en fait
nous avons d'abord découvert trois
squelettes un vieil homme par dessus une
vieille femme elle même par dessus un
enfant à cet endroit juste là et ensuite
par ici nous avons trouvé deux autres
squelettes l'un à côté de l'autre
il n'avait pas été enterré ce n'est pas
une sépulture parce qu'ils étaient sur
le sol dans des positions et
contorsionnaient qui suggèrent qu'ils
sont morts de façon traumatique et sur
place alors les gens qui sont morts à
cet endroit les hommes les femmes les
enfants était-il enfermé ici était-il
prisonniers c'est difficile à dire
en fait les murs qui bordent la cour ne
sont pas si haut que ça et ils vont même
en descendant vers l'extérieur il
semblerait que s'il avait voulu
s'échapper et que rien les en empêcher
il aurait pu le faire mais pourquoi
était-il tous rassemblés ici c'est
presque sinistre pensez vous qu'il y ait
d'autres cadavres ici oh c'est certain
j'aimerais vraiment savoir si on peut
arriver à déterminer les relations entre
ces groupes père homme femme enfant
s'ils étaient originaires de la région
aussi peut-être il venait d'ailleurs je
pense que l'on peut élucider tous là
mais ça va prendre beaucoup de temps et
une quantité considérable de fouilles
supplémentaires
même avec les fouilles il se peut que
l'on ne comprennent jamais ce qui s'est
passé ici
y at il eu une révolte ou une guerre
civile à mendes et ces gens ont ils été
exécutés y at il eu une invasion dont on
n'a jamais entendu parler et il s'agit
d'habitants de la ville tués par les
conquérants comme pour beaucoup d'autres
questions en égyptologie il n'y aura
peut-être jamais de réponse définitive
le savons qu'après ces morts la vie a
repris son cours
donc après ce désastre la ville le temps
peut semble avoir été abandonnée d'une
certaine manière mais ensuite plus tard
il ya eu davantage de construction ici
oui c'était un endroit sacré pour une
longue période
le temple a été reconstruit sous le
nouvel empire remis à neuf au cours des
siècles suivants est en fait n'a atteint
son importance actuelle pose alentours
de 550 avant jésus-christ j'aimerais
vous montrez ce dernier stade c'est en
réalité le plus grand et le plus
spectaculaire c'est une autre partie de
ce temple est mince ceci est
effectivement le saint des saints s'est
réellement spectaculaire n'est ce pas
c'est formidable
c'était le dernier élément est rajoutée
au temple c'est une grande cour fermée
avec un accès indirect pour qu'on ne
puisse pas voir directement à
l'intérieur
donc il voulait la garder secrète c'est
exact il y avait à l'intérieur quatre de
ces gigantesques chasse trois d'entre
elles ont été détruites et se sont
effondrés les vestiges subsistent et une
seule a survécu mais là aussi on a tenté
de la détruire
cela n'a pas marché alors elle est
toujours là c'est le plus grand monument
égyptien au nord des pyramides
c'est spectaculaire surtout vu d'ici il
y en avait quatre comme celle ci oui
c'est cela il y en avait quatre chacune
contenant un dieu c'est exact chacune
avait une représentation du dieu bélier
le dieu bélier est tenu en très haute
estime par les habitants de mendes il
symbolise la puissance et la force qui
devait assurer la prospérité des
habitants de la ville
il s'agissait donc d'un centre vital
pour la ville entière oui c'était d'une
certaine manière un point central pour
la communauté toute entière
tous se considérer à des degrés variés
comme des adeptes du dieu bélier ce
temple était au coeur d'une grande ville
combien de temps tout cela at il duré
aux alentours de 5000 ans je suppose on
pouvait sans doute voir ce temple encore
debout au moyen-âge ce n'est qu'après
cette période qu'il a été détruit pour
ces pierres et pierre calcaire surtout
et à la suite des déprédations des
premiers archéologues qui étaient en
réalité des chasseurs de trésors tous
nos tempes s'est déroulée
[Musique]
des oiseaux nichent qu ici maintenant
mais il y à 2500 en un dieu vivant ici
et après la nuit terrible de la tragédie
inexpliquée de mendes sous l'ancien
empire
il sourit à nouveau sur cette ville
ancienne les meilleures années de mendes
se situe entre 600 et 330 avant
jésus-christ les vestiges des remparts
de la ville domine ce qu'était un port
fluvial actif des navires marchands
venaient d'aussi loin que la grèce
apportaient leur chargement au port
débordant d'activité de mendes du bois
de construction et d huile était échangé
contre les céréales égyptienne de l'or
et du vin
[Musique]
aujourd'hui le cours du nil s'est
éloigné de cet endroit le port qui était
jadis plein d'animations n'est plus
désormais qu'à tailler de broussailles
le sable donald raid fort et moi sommes
montés sur les remparts de l'ancienne
ville et il m'a aidé à imaginer le grand
port qui autrefois prospérer à cet
endroit
à l'arrière-plan là où se trouvent les
rangées d'arbres vous auriez vu le
fleuve le bras du nil desservant mendes
mais ici au premier plan vous auriez eu
le port qui s'avançait un grand port de
forme triangulaire
c'était donc un vrai centre de commerce
oui en effet pour autant qu'on puisse en
juger il n'y a pas de quai nous avons
trouvé une ancre au cours de nos
fouilles ce qui suffit pratiquement à
prouver qu'il s'agit bien d'un port
navire devait être échoué
ils devaient utiliser un poteau ou
d'amarrage qu'il plantait est installée
une passerelle de débarquement puis les
porteurs arrivés avec leurs balais je
sais quoi d'autre
l'egypte avait tellement à offrir elle
était incroyablement riche en ressources
de toute sorte qu'elle avait l'effet
d'un aimant géant sur les autres peuples
du monde
tout le monde voulait venir ici tout le
monde voulait faire du commerce si vous
étiez phéniciens savall et même le coup
de construire votre propre navire est de
vous associer avec un voisin important
et d'envoyer votre navire ici en egypte
vous pouviez faire fortune
en plus de l'ancien port donne a laissé
également d'en apprendre davantage sur
la façon dont vivaient des gens à mendes
par ici est ce que ce sont les vestiges
de la ville elle-même ça c'est la ville
en fait vous voyez à cet endroit c'est
de la terre de premiers choix parce que
le vent du nord souffle dessus
c'est un emplacement fantastique du coup
il était occupé par des bâtiments
publics importants peut-être la demeure
du gouverneur ou de quiconque était haut
responsable si on effectuer des fouilles
à cet endroit
nous avons creusé par là en partie on
trouverait de grandes enceintes avec des
bâtiments assez bien construit qui
servait de logement aux scribes et à
l'élite de la communauté c'est
d'ailleurs vous pouvez voir qu'il ya des
murs encore debout qui subissent
l'érosion et nous pouvons faire un plan
de ces murs qui nous donnera une
meilleure idée des grands bâtiments
publics dont il s'agissait
j'adorerais aller là bas c'est au
programme si je viens c'est longtemps
pour ça ce qui me frappe d'abord alors
que je me tiens ici c'est que vous êtes
en train de découvrir toute une ville
c'est énorme
vous avez des temples vous n'avez pas un
mais deux ports vous avez une ville
entière qui a été à peine touchée par
les fleuves et c'est aussi un endroit
d'une extrême beauté
c'est absolument saisissant
[Musique]
la vie à mendes a un caractère
cosmopolite unique
cependant la vie ici devait beaucoup
ressembler à la vie dans la plupart des
autres villes de l'egypte ancienne
nous avons une idée de ce que c'était de
vivre dans une ville égyptienne les
villes étaient plutôt surpeuplée a bien
fait en général pas de grandes voies de
circulation les villes étaient traversés
par des réseaux de rue plutôt étroites
et assez irrégulière dans leur
disposition les maisons était blottie
les unes contre les autres
de telle manière que l'on a les grandes
maisons des membres de l'élite entouré
par celle des gens statut bien inférieur
la seule ressource importante dont
l'egypte était dépourvu était du bois de
construction de qualité les plus riches
pouvaient faire venir du bois de
charpente de la lointaine phénicie le
liban actuel les pauvres se contenter
des troncs de palmiers
[Musique]
que ce soit dans l'egypte ancienne ou
l'egypte actuelle la solution à la
pénurie de bois de charpente consiste à
construire la plupart des maisons en
briques de terre les maisons faites de
ces briques épaisses sont confortables
et restent fraîches d'après ce qu'on
peut voir de l'agencement des maisons de
leurs dispositions et des scènes qu'elle
montre qu'elle représente de manière
générale je pense qu'elle était très
propre et très bien entretenu mais
également qu'elles étaient joliment
décorées et peintes souvent la propreté
des égyptiens et la fierté qu'ils tirent
de leur maison ne semble pas s'appliquer
aux rues devant leur porte d'entrée les
installations sanitaires sont quasi
inexistants qui compris dans les maisons
de l'élite
il n'y a pas d'eau courante deux
systèmes d'écoulement des eaux usées et
rien qui s'en rapproche nous savons
qu'il faisait très attention à garder
leur maison propre et qu'il les nettoyer
constamment je tends son arrêt des
détritus venant grossir les tas
d'ordures
ces tas d'ordures se trouvait juste au
coin de la rue en fait chacun jeter ses
ordures derrière chez soi tout comme
leurs concitoyens les habitants de
mendes était sans doute assez grégaire
se rassemblant près des temples et des
places de marché pour voir leurs voisins
et entendre les nouvelles du jour
c'est dans ce genre d'environnement
social qui nous aurait été possible de
constater à quel point les égyptiens
faisaient attention à leur apparence
physique
tout comme les gens d'aujourd'hui les
égyptiens étaient très soucieux de leur
apparence et je ne pense pas que tout se
résumer à l'image mais elle joue est
certainement un rôle important
de ce fait les égyptiens consacré
apparemment beaucoup de temps à leur
part vers le tissu favori pour la
fabrication de presque tous les
vêtements égyptien et elle l'a bien que
l'egypte soit aujourd'hui célèbre pour
son coton cette fibre n'était pas
cultivé dans l'ancien temps c'est le lin
que l'on retrouvé sur les métiers à
tisser et que l'on filait pour en faire
une variété de vêtements pour le roi et
ses sujets pour les paysans
l'habillement se limitait à un pagne des
tofs en revanche pour les égyptiens
fortune et le lin offrait une variété
incroyable et il pouvait servir à
fabriquer n'importe quoi depuis de belle
jupe plissée jusqu'à des châles très fin
et délicat quand on se penche sur l'art
des anciens égyptiens on pourrait penser
que les égyptiens se promenait
habituellement vêtu très légèrement
profitant de la douceur de leur climat
je suis certain qu'au printemps et en
été cela devait être le cas
cependant en egypte les hivers sont en
réalité très froid et il existe en fait
des références textuelles indiquant que
les gens portaient alors des vêtements
assez lourd des longs vêtements et des
robes pour se protéger du froid
[Musique]
des documents retrouvés dans les ruines
d'un village montre aussi que très
longtemps avant l'ouverture de la
première boutique
les égyptiennes possédait déjà un sens
de la mode et de la vanité
je pense réellement que les femmes de
l'egypte ancienne avait une conscience
aiguë de leur habillement est l'un des
commentaires que l'on retrouve plusieurs
fois émane de femmes se plaignant
qu'elles n'ont rien à se mettre elle
avait évidemment de quoi s'habiller mais
cela ne suffisait pas bien que de
nombreux égyptiens appartenant à la
classe ouvrière passent leurs journées
pieds nus pour se déplacer en egypte il
faut souvent marcher sur des pierres
tranchantes et du sable chaud
les sandales sont populaires les riches
peuvent se permettre de faire fabriquer
les leurs en cuir les pauvres se
contente de chaussures fait de paille
les bijoux sont un élément essentiel de
l'image que les égyptiens y compris les
pauvres veulent donner d'eux-mêmes
cependant le maquillage reste le plus
important des soins de beauté et la
partie centrale du style personnel en
tant qu'acteur je ne pouvais résister à
l envie de voir de quoi j'aurais l'air
en égyptien le maquillage a probablement
fait ses débuts comme une sorte de
protection contre le soleil les membres
des deux sexes l'utilisent et la plupart
des classes sociales depuis le paysan
jusqu'au roi ne sortirait pas sans y
compris pendant la journée de travail le
maquillage des yeux remplit plusieurs
fonctions
il prévient les infections et garde les
mouches à distance et la croyance
populaire veut qu'ils possèdent des
propriétés magiques
il réduit également les classes gland du
soleil un peu à la manière des joueurs
de baseball qui arborent des bandes
noires sous les yeux locre rouge été
broyés pour créer une sorte de rouge
elle joue et on le mélange est aussi
avec de l'huile et de la grèce pour
fabriquer ce que nous appellerions rouge
à lèvres
en plus de tout cela
l'armoire à pharmacie égyptienne
contenait des déodorants variés des
dépilatoire même de la crème antirides
la plupart des égyptiens se raser la
tête et il avait bien raison non
seulement cette esthétique mais en plus
ça évite les poux néanmoins on ne veut
pas non plus que le soleil ne tape sur
la tête toute la journée par conséquent
beaucoup d'égyptiens peu importe leur
casse sociale portent des perruques les
pauvres fabrique les leurs à partir de
fibres végétales les riches peuvent se
permettre au sel en vrais cheveux cela
implique qu'ils passaient sans doute de
mauvais moments avec leurs cheveux voilà
ça y est voilà deux côtés d'air frais
pour aller faire la fête à memphis ou à
thèbes n'ont peut-être pas entièrement
prêt
dans l'egypte ancienne
comment les gens vivaient et est souvent
déterminée par où il vit
certaines colonies ont commencé près de
port d'autres à l'intersection de route
de commerce d'autres encore à des
endroits stratégiques le long du nil
cependant beaucoup de renseignements
dont on dispose sur la vie urbaine en
egypte proviennent des vestiges d'une
ville unique qui existait seulement pour
s'occuper de cimetière ces cimetières
sont les légendaires tombeau dans la
vallée des rois et la vallée des rennes
elle se situe sur la rive ouest du nil
en face du grand centre religieux de
thèbes
[Musique]
nous trouvons dans le couloir d'entrée
de l'un des nombreux tombeau de la
vallée des rois
chacun de ces grands espaces devait être
creusée dans la roche solide et
nécessité le travail de plusieurs
centaines d'hommes certains creuser et
enlever la roche d'autres dessinée et
sculpter les bas-reliefs dans la pierre
calcaire d'autres encore peignait les
scène stupéfiante que nous voyons autour
de nous un village particulier a été
créé afin de fournir des logements à
cette main d'oeuvre qualifiée
donc très précieuse
[Musique]
ce village de travailleurs porte
aujourd'hui le nom de deir el médina qui
signifie en arabe
le monastère de la ville
[Musique]
à compter de 1500 avant jésus-christ cet
endroit désolé abriter les artisans qui
crée les grands tombeau pour la noblesse
égyptienne l'emplacement choisi pour le
village étaient loin d'être idéales
l'implacable soleil égyptien est brûlant
à cet endroit et il n'y a ni eau ni
arbre
[Musique]
on ne peut même pas apercevoir le nil
qui coule à un peu plus de trois
kilomètres de là mais l'emplacement de
deir el médina présente un avantage il
ne faut pas marcher longtemps pour se
rendre au chantier des tombeaux dans la
vallée
[Musique]
les hommes qui travaillaient sur les
temples déménager d'un site à l'autre
une fois le temple achever le travail
dans la vallée des rois ne s'arrête pas
avant longtemps aussi les hommes qui
travaillent conservent leur emploi et
maintiennent leurs familles et leurs
relations et nous possédons une
documentation complète sur ce qui se
passait là bas
les archéologues qui ont découvert deir
el médina ont eu la chance de trouver
également un dépotoir qui recèle des
renseignements précieux
nous avons beaucoup de chance parce
qu'ils ont laissé derrière eux leurs
papiers de fortune parce que c'est bien
de cela qu'il s'agit
c'est ce que les égyptologues de métier
appel à nostra con ça peut être un
tesson de pierre calcaire comme vous le
voyez ici où il peut s'agir d'un tesson
de poterie et poteries cassées
c'est essentiellement un support sur
lequel vous écrivez à l'encré fait d'un
mélange de noir de fumée et d'eau
heureusement nous avons mis à jour une
cachette importante rempli de ce genre
de choses
[Musique]
ces petits éclats de pierre sont les
vestiges de documents d'agenda et de
note informelle qui nous offre un aperçu
d'une valeur inestimable de la vie des
égyptiens qui résidaient ici c'est la
seule ville de l'ancienne egypte sur
laquelle on dispose d'autant de
documents les ouvriers de deir el médina
était très estimé et bien payé il existe
même un document prenant acte des
ouvriers s'étant mises en grève pour
protester contre des injustices les
habitants de ce village n'était pas des
esclaves
il y à cette représentation par cécile b
2000 qui montre que les tombeaux sont
construits par des prisonniers qui sont
ensuite tué sauvagement afin de garder
l'emplacement des tombes secret et ce
n'était simplement pas le cas plusieurs
centaines de personnes auraient vécu ici
à un moment donné l'état fournissait des
maisons aux ouvriers qui étaient
construites spécialement pour eux les
maisons étaient organisées le long de
voies de passage qui ressemblaient
davantage à des ruelles cas des rues il
y avait souvent peu d'espacé libre à
l'extérieur mais l'intérieur était
confortable et contenaient même des
meubles
il y avait très peu de meubles et
pourtant nous avons au moins deux ou
trois tombeau je crois dans le cimetière
de deir el médina qui contenait environ
25 à 30 meubles surtout de petites
chaises et des tabourets en bois
[Musique]
il est évident qu'il travaillait très
dur cependant travailler dur veut pas
dire que la vie elle-même était dur et
maison qu'ils habitaient tu es certes
petit mais il devait être réellement
agréable d'y vivre
[Musique]
ces murs bas sont tout ce qui nous reste
des maisons de deir el médina
aujourd'hui elle paraît soulim en terre
inhospitalière néanmoins pendant près de
quatre siècles s'est bâti sont
accueillis des générations d'ouvriers et
leur famille leur vie de famille doit
avoir sembler familière pour ceux qui
vivaient il ya 3500 ans
[Musique]
c'est le début d'une nouvelle semaine de
travail pour le tailleur de pierre qui
vit dans cette maison de deir el médina
en été il peut faire très chaud même la
nuit alors la famille dort sans doute
ici sur le toit le matin le tailleur
décent et trouve les jouets de ses
enfants sur les marches de l'escalier
encore une fois et il entre dans cette
pièce la cuisine où son épouse est
probablement déjà en train de lui
préparer son petit déjeuner dans l'âtre
ici c'est le retrouver les ingrédients
au frais dans ce scellier en bas des
marches dans le coin ils proviennent
également de la meule par ici y at il
pour le petit-déjeuner vient
certainement du pain et sans doute du
fromage des oignons et de la bière non
sérieusement la bière est alors un
aliment de base très important pour les
égyptiens sa teneur en alcool est peu
élevée et elle doit avoir la consistance
de la soupe on ne peut pas tout avoir
donc il vient ici dans cette petite
chambre qui est utilisé en hiver et
s'habille ça ne lui pose pas de problème
réel car tout ce qu'il a à se mettre est
un pagne des tofs et peut-être des
sandales en paille il semble néanmoins
que la plupart des hommes travaillent
pieds nus ensuite il va dans le salon
qui sera tout là se trouve une niche
avec les pénates qui sont en fait des
ancêtres de la famille
de ce côté il ya un fauteuil celui du
maître de maison
il ne faut pas oublier que ces ouvriers
sont des ouvriers qualifiés alors leurs
maisons sont sans doute des lieux
agréables des murs plat très joliment
blanchis à la chaux des nattes sur le
sol des paniers des meubles en bois par
ici se trouve la pièce commune du devant
avec cette banquette lit dans le coin il
faut savoir qu'il n'y a pas de fenêtre
dans ces maisons afin d'empêcher la
chaleur d'entrée en revanche il ya des
fentes pour l'aération dans le plafond
du coup toute la maison doit être assez
sombre mais assez fraîches malgré la
chaleur estivale intense et après tout
ce n'est pas si mal pour un ouvrier sa
famille en 1200 avant jésus-christ
maintenant au travail
alors que les hommes du village s'en
vont au travail ils laissent derrière
eux un village qui fonctionne
parfaitement
[Musique]
les garçons et les jeunes hommes sont
répartis en équipes qui seraient
approvisionne en nourriture et en eau
dans la vallée plus bas les femmes sont
occupés aux tâches ménagères
elle recherche fréquemment des idées qui
leur permettent de gagner un peu
d'argent supplémentaire est l'une de ces
idées consiste à vendre des mèches de
lente qu'elle tisse pour les lampes dont
leurs maris se servent dans l'obscurité
des tombeaux voici le chemin qui mène à
la vallée des rois juste au delà du
sommet de cette montagne en bas c'est la
ville de deir el médina notre tailleur
de pierre ne la reverra sans doute pas
avant neuf jours c'est la durée de la
semaine de travail durant la semaine
la plupart des ouvriers préfère rester
dans de petites chutes plus proche des
tombeaux dans la vallée alors peut-être
ici se retourne t-il pour adresser un
signe de la main en guise d'un au revoir
à sa femme et à ses enfants en bas dans
le village
ensuite il reprend sa marche d'une
demi-heure pour regagner son chantier
difficile dans les tombeaux vers 1100
avant jésus-christ l'egypte connaît une
période d'instabilité des envahisseurs
étrangers franchise ses frontières et
les conflits civils font rage au sein du
pays il est possible que les habitants
du village se soient sentis exposés et
sans défense face aux dangers qui les
entoure
après 400 ans les ouvriers abandonne
finalement deir el médina
[Musique]
cet endroit où des égyptiens ordinaires
avaient établi leur foyer pendant si
longtemps tombe rapidement dans l'oubli
les toits s'effondrent les murs se
change en gravats et le sable du désert
rattrape finalement le village
plus de trente siècles plus tard deir el
médina revit heureusement ses habitants
ont laissé de nombreuses traces de leur
présence
ils nous ont fourni une merveilleuse
image de la vie quotidienne qui
prospérait dans cet endroit désolé il ya
très longtemps
[Musique]
voir des anciennes sociétés est révélé
au travers d'événements le plus souvent
dominé par les hommes
il en est ainsi de l'egypte
les documents qui subsistent décrivant
la civilisation égyptienne sont remplis
des récits d'hommes souverain de prêtres
de guerrier et de scribe
mais évidemment l'histoire vraie de
l'egypte ancienne et tout autant
l'histoire de ces femmes
[Musique]
le rôle des femmes dans la société
égyptienne est très différent d'autres
civilisations anciennes
les sociétés babylonienne assyrienne et
israélites sont dominés par des formes
extrêmes de contrôle patriarcal même la
grèce berceau de la démocratie traite
ces femmes à peine mieux que ses
domestiques
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en revanche en egypte on peut établir
que l'égalité juridique des femmes
remontent à 2007 100 ans avant
jésus-christ en egypte les femmes
pouvaient aller au tribunal elle pouvait
devenir propriétaires de bien servir de
témoins signer des documents elles
pouvaient légué leur bien à qui elle
voulait j'ai souvent fait remarquer en
particulier aux jeunes femmes que les
égyptiennes qui était considéré par leur
état comme des personnes juridiques
indépendantes à part entière avait
davantage de droits aux yeux de la loi
que certaines femmes n'en avais aux
états unis jusque dans les années 50
[Musique]
l'une des conséquences de l'égalité
juridique entre hommes et femmes et que
ces dernières doivent effectuer leur
service annuel comme les hommes en
travaillant sur les tombeaux et temple
construit par le pharaon chaque année
les femmes écrase des pigments de
peinture pour décorer des tombeaux
presse les sandales et des paniers pour
les ouvriers il y a des preuves
indiquant que des femmes pilotes et même
des bateaux sur le nil
en règle générale les femmes n'occupent
pas de poste important dans la vie
publique et la vie politique égyptienne
pour une égyptienne moyenne la majeure
partie de ses responsabilités se limite
au foyer le travail de la femme est dans
la maison
il ne faut pas oublier que le travail
dans la maison ne se résume pas à sortir
les poubelles c'est presque une
industrie de production
il faut faire le pain tous les jours et
ce sont les femmes qui sont au moulin et
ce sont les femmes qui font le tissage
au foyer les femmes devaient apprendre à
filer de manière à ce qu'il y est à ses
deux fils pour le métier à tisser afin
de fabriquer les toffes pour les
vêtements de toute la famille le procédé
de création de chaque fil de lin compte
24 étapes
c'est donc incroyablement compliqué et
une jeune femme se devait de maîtriser
le procédé est ensuite apprendre à
tisser
c'est l'une des meilleures qualités
jamais produite dans le
c'est léger et comme de la soie presque
transparent dans les familles de
fermiers les femmes s'occupent des
canards et des oies mais aide également
au chant quand c'est nécessaire
les femmes sont également responsables
du commerce des produits fermiers et des
objets manufacturés comme les paniers
les poteries sur la place du marché
la vie productive d'une femme commence à
l'âge de 12 ou 13 ans en tout premier
lieu elle est censée trouver un mari et
commencer une famille on attache
beaucoup d'importance au fait d'avoir
des enfants tôt dans la vie
[Musique]
il faut commencer par dire que les
égyptiennes sont parmi les plus belles
femmes que vous ayez jamais vu de
longues jambes des petits seins c'est un
nom très droite vous avez ses hanches
superbe de l'ombre a presque des corps
de danseuse
on se fait la cour de manière très
informelle est étonnamment sans grand
rituel ou restriction les relations
entre les jeunes hommes et femmes n'ont
rien de prudes la poésie amoureuse
semble suggérer qu'il y a des relations
sexuelles avant le mariage
dans de nombreux cas du moins dans les
poèmes amoureux le jeune homme le
prétendant rendrait visite à la jeune
femme chez elle où une jeune femme
partirait en courant rejoindre son
amoureux dans son lit il y a donc une
représentation explicite de l'amour
sexuelles avant le mariage
[Musique]
déjà dans l'ancien temps la romance est
souvent exprimé au travers de la musique
les égyptiens adorent leur musique elle
fait partie intégrante de tous les
aspects de leur vie
[Musique]
[Rires]
malheureusement nous n'avons pas une
idée précise de ce à quoi ressemblait la
musique égyptienne
cependant nous avons les paroles de
certaines de leurs chansons
ceci est un extrait d'une chanson
d'amour chanté par une femme à son
amoureux qu'elle appelle frère mon frère
il est agréable d'aller à la mare afin
de me baigner en ta présence que je te
laisse voir ma beauté dans ma tunique de
l'ain royal le plus fin lorsqu'il est
mouillé au le plus beau mon désir sera
ici mon frère ne peut être avec moi ce
soir alors je suis comme celui qui est
au fond de la tombe
car ne tue pas la santé et la vie
vous savez on n'écrit plus à aujourd'hui
[Musique]
les filles ont le droit de se marier dès
qu'elles atteignent la puberté pour les
garçons c'est un peu plus tard entre 16
et 20 ans bien que la cour d'un jeune
couple ait pu être totalement romantique
l'événement du mariage lui-même ne l'est
pas du tout en egypte le mariage était
une institution est pas un sacrement
pour autant qu'on sache il n'y avait pas
vraiment de cérémonie de mariage de
familles pouvaient accepter qu'un couple
se marie ou un couple pourrait décider
de se marier avec le soutien de leurs
familles mais il n'y a pas de réelle
cérémonie de mariage
la virginité n'était exigé ni de la
future mariée ni du futur marié
cependant après le mariage la fidélité
est prise très au sérieux
on présume qu'une fois mariée le couple
sera fidèle et en réalité d'après ce que
l'on a appris des textes des sages de
l'époque
cela s'applique au mari comme à la femme
la fidélité dans le mariage est
considérée comme la façon convenable de
vivre le divorce n'est pas rare parmi
les égyptiens et les deux partenaires
peuvent amorcer la procédure il n'y a
pas de stigmates sociale il arrive
fréquemment que les hommes et les femmes
divorcées se remarie en dépit de leur
attitude vis-à-vis du divorce
l'institution du mariage est au coeur de
la société égyptienne
les anciens égyptiens sont souvent
représentés dans les bras l'un de
l'autre
mari et femme et c'est très charmant
parce que ce n'est pas un grand
témoignage d'affection mais c'est très
discret et ils ont tous de l'air très
heureux le concept de la famille et un
sentiment d'affection est d'amener les
uns pour les autres étaient très forts
dans l'egypte ancienne et le sont encore
aujourd'hui il est tentant pour la
société moderne de présumer que la
technologie nous a apporté une
perspective unique sur la vie que
l'égyptien moyen n'aurait pas pu
connaître dans l'egypte ancienne
mais ce genre de préjugés revient à nier
les faits appartenant à l'histoire de
cet endroit il est évident que les
anciens égyptiens aimer leur pays
chérissez leurs familles et aspirer à la
même peine est la même satisfaction que
nous des milliers d'années plus tard les
éléments essentiels qui font que la vie
vaut la peine d'être vécue et est chéri
par les peuples anciens comme ils le
sont aujourd'hui par nous
[Musique]
dans le prochain épisode de l'egypte au
delà des pyramides
vous savez il existe des histoires
d'horreur théologique la mort n'était
pas une fin mais le début de l'éternité
c'est simplement un changement d'état le
monde de l'au delà qui récompense les
gens aisés et ferait des pauvres les
pauvres craignais cette autre monde
peter woodward étudie les mystères de
l'amour éternel
dans le prochain épisode de l'egypte ont
de l'avis pirates
[Musique]